we're back with the bewitching and
hathaway oh yeah i said it by the way
speaking of
our virtual friends and family have
dressed up as witches
in honor of your movie oh my god that's
the cutest thing
yeah you guys look awesome by the way
you i mean look how cute they are do you
mind if one asks you a question really
quick i believe that's happening
let's go um first up we have haley
hi oh my gosh this is a halloween dream
come true i'm such a fan
all right miss anne hathaway i was
wondering what are your boys dressing up
for is halloween
uh great question love by the way that
was like an
excellent zoom halloween costume you
could be easter on the bottom but
from the shoulders up it's wonderful
so jonathan is very into the cars
movie franchise so he is going to be
lightning mcqueen and adam is going to
be doc hudson
and jack who's 11 months old is climbing
on everything so he's going to be a
monkey
and i am going to be holding him all
night so i will be a treat
i love that this is tracy and we have a
question from
you hello tracy hi how are you
excellent my question is you've played
so many different roles
is there anything that you haven't
played yet that you're interested in
oh why yes there's lots and lots of
things hopefully one will be directed by
drew
um and um but in terms of roles that i
think have come and gone because i'm not
sure
well to be honest because i think that
there are people who probably are just
it's their time more than my time i wish
that i'd played juliet in romeo and
juliet
and i i wish that i'd played eliza
doolittle in
my fair lady but
yeah excellent i think we can make this
happen and they're definitely they're
timeless pieces
and they're relevant at every single
stage day and age so
when we have our future family we can
just work shop it
in the house it's going to be beautiful
and
then you know we'll we'll do remakes of
those
beautiful stories and i
think the world of you by the way
complete off
topic your house um in
it was in i think it was architectural
digest or maybe i'll decor
it was it's i fantasize about it by the
way i'll be living there soon
it's your house come on gosh it's the
most what
what color do you want your onesie to be
yellow please hello of course sunshine
yes yes yes onesie ready by this evening
don't worry
and i'm so excited to move into that
fabulous house i'm not kidding i dream
of that house it is so special
and so unique your taste is impeccable
i'm not surprised
um and roll dolls the witches is on hbo
max
and i thank you for your time you look
as beautiful as
ever and i'm sending you so much love
and light really and truly i'm so happy
to be with you right now thank you for
coming on the show thank you for having
me on your wonderful show
[Music]
you